que puedes contarnos de las reacciones
de china a lo que está ocurriendo
puede la prensa china no ha dicho mucho
aún del asunto es conocida su falta de
reflejos en cuestiones internacionales
porque hay muchos filtros previos y en
menos de media hora empezará a la rueda
de prensa del ministerio de exteriores
así que tenemos que atenernos a lo que
ha dicho hasta ahora y ha sido muy poco
ha pido a las partes mesura y que
negocien para solventar los conflictos
es decir se ha mantenido fiel al
principio sagrado de su diplomacia que
es el de no interferir en asuntos
externos y es improbable que se vaya a
desviar de ahí ni un solo centímetro el
conflicto pone a china en un lugar
complicado por un lado está claro que
está más cerca de rusia que de eeuu pero
por otro las declaraciones de
independencia le incomodan lo que es
comprensible por su compleja situación
interna y además es muy respetuosa con
la soberanía ajena de hecho lo más
rescatable de sus declaraciones hasta
ahora es que ha subrayado el respeto a
la soberanía de ucrania y eso se aplica
ahora dicho china no apoyo a rusia en
sus operaciones en crimea ni en
ni en afasia ni osetia del sur quizá
rusia pueda recibir como mucho de china
algún guiño diplomática pero nada más y
desde luego podemos descartar ningún
apoyo militar
adrián quizás nos puedes contar un poco
de las relaciones históricas entre china
y rúsia
sí bueno las relaciones se han pasado
por diferentes etapas y ahora
precisamente se cumplen 50 años de el
histórico viaje de nixon a pekín que
tuvo como finalidad que ambos se
protegieran de moscú de hecho mao tenía
en aquellos momentos una guerra nuclear
con rusia las relaciones han mejorado
mucho especialmente
con si sin fin y vladimir putin es
evidente que tienen una química personal
les unen los intercambios comerciales y
sobre todo lo que le unen son los
lamentos sobre lo que perciben como una
hostilidad estadounidense que apadrina
washington apadrina organizaciones
militares en sus patios traseros ya sea
la otan en europa el este o el autobús
en el asia-pacífico pero insisto eso
difícilmente se va a traducir en un
apoyo a rusia en el asunto de ucrania
además nos olvidar que china también
tiene muy buenas relaciones con ucrania
hace poco se cumplieron los 30 años del
establecimiento de esas relaciones y
china reafirmó su compromiso con la
integridad de su territorio